hello it skims so I would try a new
intro never again feels like it's been
quite a while since I've just sit back
and played again for you guys that has
not been live streamed but I thought
that was the only way to play this game
because this is the second game from
kill Monday games and they are the
creators behind Fran bow and if you
remember me playing Fran bow then you
are a long time watcher and hey thank
you for your commitments I appreciate
that
yes and if not then you can check out
Fran bow their previous game it's all on
my channel I play through the whole game
it was very very good the art style is
very cute but the gameplay is really
darn creepy I'm not gonna spoil the
story for you because that's pretty
troublesome whistle oh oh
but it was extremely enjoyable it was a
lovely little pointing click game and
I'm excited to see what little
misfortune has to offer
those things were in from beau those
little like swinging heads anyway it's a
fox ok
the Acorn dude was in front bow - okay I
forgot them
okay
so this maybe still plays around with
parallel worlds which is nice
the art style is very reminiscent of
Rambo but damn the quality has
definitely ups
welcome to my game now where I'll be
your hope and humble narrator the rules
of this game are simple played until the
end give me the word
[Music]
this is mrs. fortune
she's a wonderful child from a not a
wonderful family a little sparkle for
you and a little sparkle for you a
little bit for me Oh
the sad part is Tuesday that day she
would have died oh oh you can
are you insane my head or something hmm
well okay yes why is she not freaking
out about me buying into that okay they
know nobody said anything about anyone
dying today nothing that were negative
I have prepared a game for you again
really for me if you can reach the end
of the game
I'll give you eternal happiness deal
eternal happiness I guess I could give
that to my mommy
oh that's my
ah the parallel universe destined to
worry yes
your first mission is to leave the house
okay mission that is a mission it's
every day how can I leave the house
oh okay so it's not so pointing like
anymore oh okay
what did I just say this is my secret
hiding spot
Oh impressive but why do you need a
hiding spot I don't like it when Mom you
love it argue too much do when I come
here I can dream and travel far away I
see my lover's can probably relate to
that one sassy I like to play a lot with
my toys
mr. sad Rock he's my favorite he looks
like um you know that pokemon from
swords and shields sobel Zabul i like to
play a lot with my toys I like to talk
to them because it's did you draw all
this hello diary at school I drew and at
home I was at my hiding spot talking to
pubsey and I heard it Oh bub see is that
Fox okay I saw a fox
oh no it's not was a Bob see her teddy
I guess so folks walking outside
everyone he's got Benjamin okay he's
Benjamin hello diary my dad lied to me
again not going out to the park today
I've it was a pretty but he doesn't care
I feel sad I cried but told mommy I'm
okay I'm afraid if I tell her I'm sorry
she will be angry sometimes I don't know
how to feel
nobody's teaching me how to feel I wish
you in school they teaches where
feelings come from but for reals
no fairytales
yikes forever yikes forever
hello sorry is it okay to have feelings
for a fox she found she fancied a box
I mean squat back say Benjamin the Fox
came to visit when I was playing outside
and we'd look to each other and my heart
felt warm and like if I was about to
vomit but I did good way then he ran
away because my mommy shouts but dinner
was ready
hello diary my daddy hid mommy
oh is that supposed to be no more [ __ ] I
hate people I love it doesn't feel right
maybe daddy can't sees her in me too
when he hits mummy I promise I will
never be like my daddy I will never be
like my daddy oh wait I already said
that I paid today that I took a plane to
Japan it's so interesting things I know
about Japan because my friend is
Japanese and he likes sushi sushi is
darn good my Japanese friend speaks
Japanese that's my problem I say can we
talk it's hardest on each other it's
confusing but I like him he is a pair of
sweet boots but in cowboy hat his name
is Hiro and he's a ghost he always a
ghost oh so do you think she can see we
all go some things from from other
universes and that's why there's like
parallel universe that's cool I do mean
[ __ ] oh but I never gave it to him
that's heat up my Japanese friend he
said girls that go
I like how she talks it's very endearing
hello diary look I have this up from
school it's super shiny and we use it to
make Christmas cards I think Christmas
pots are pretty but I don't believe in
Santa is for real if a mind could give
everyone a gift why can't I give Bobby
more water and food I saw a TV show with
people from other countries having
nothing to eat anyway
I don't believe Santa's real but the
glitter is amazing it makes me think
that all that makes me sad and angry can
be sprinkle with sparkles about prettier
that makes me a little less sad I want
picking tomatoes my grandma it's not so
nice and it's butterflies and some
insects I ate two two miners and then I
was stuffed Rudy - 2 - tomorrow's ok
hello diary I was riding my tricycle I
don't have the money for a bicycle and I
look straight into the Sun I started
crying because it hurt my eyes yeah I
learned that young - my mommy said that
I should not look directly at it
ok she writes a lot of things in her
diary the cake looks yummy
oh she's gonna be a lady Fox hell yeah
look at that picture
I will such a baby very cute no I'm
always she's good ok how do I go by X
it is Popsy the guardian of the sacred
ARS Bobson you see his eye he got that
from a battle against the monster a
monster that sounds scary
reminds me of a my I used to have like a
really old teddy when I was a kid and he
lost his eye and now my mom took him to
Teddy Hospital and she put a patch over
it
she caught me I got to choose the
material that I wanted oh I'll take the
coloring book yeah sure right now why
was that it seemed like why do that seem
like such a big decision it's just a
coloring book
okay I'm freaked out
[Music]
so that's my little metal handsome Fox
in this picture it's the folks I see
outside my window sometimes I go him
Benjamin
he's a really cute Fox yeah I don't care
much for Fox
[Music]
do you have any music in there I like to
move my body mm-hmm it's the music that
goes on forever
wait okay I love this I love all the
tiny details and down this looks so
gorgeous
okay got my glitter so if I start to
feel less I saw a monster in here once I
showed it the finger I'll try that next
time before you leave which toy do you
choose no you can only choose one and
remember your choice is much more
important than you think
shoes Sabu Super Bowl three shows the
stone body threw at me once interests me
because he's our son get up
don't disturb that's a very clever thank
you thank you
oh my gosh blood oh man so you know I
like to sprinkle sparkling things so
they become fabulous
[Music]
hey you on the other side of the screen
hey hey man I told you she was going to
die today let's keep that a secret
between us okay yeah hey Benjamin did
you see okay I'm ready to enjoy this and
why is those pictures so creepy
uh-huh you guys I'm sorry but your grind
its tariffs grandma she was a poor - you
still wear a diaper can't relate hold
shift to run okay cool but I want to
check out oh oh that was a beautiful
example of course and effect please
don't tell me don't worry you can trust
me okay he's in your head girl
really I could try to fix it yeah I'm
getting day job here yeah yeah fix it
fix it
although I shouldn't do if I go with my
day job babe cuz I'm gonna cut myself
this is what happens to me when I was
kid
[Music]
skirts ooh maybe I could try to fix it
cuz uh when I was a kid I broke of Oz
and I felt like really bad so um I got
all the little pieces like this and then
fit them together this is a way um and
then obviously he didn't really remain
fixed either my mom found out and then
she was like you should have just told
me because you could have really hurt
yourself
um that's how my mom talks
and then yeah she said she wouldn't have
been mad but she would have been more
mad if I had hurt myself trying to fix
it oh oh and from then I just stopped
telling lies because I realized this
there's no point Wow I say that who do I
think I am
I still tell some lies everyone lies
sometimes I mean he me go I'm the best
[Music]
oh I mean all right I was like am I
missing bits I don't know why you go
someone like this
[Music]
uh hello haha but would I put you where
do you go
are you Aaron yeah yeah you're the site
[Music]
it's like perfect
how was it saying together have no glue
oh man she married daddy because she was
expecting me she wanted to have an
abortion against the law
your mama's probably opening up so much
yes look that's me
mommy told me I have to smile even when
I'm a son that's okay you don't have to
smile around me
my daddy's friend was a hunter and
killed this moose he's dr. Erica she
thought his gun was a toy
she said bang bang to her mommy and
daddy then her parents died so she was
so sad hmm I'm sorry that's not but it's
like this is exactly what farmer was
like it looks so cute and then there
were just things that were just so dog
like you couldn't even expect them
coming oh it smells like cigarettes in
here yeah that's my mommy she also likes
to drink juice a lot are you ready to
complete your first mission yes I am I'm
gonna get that brush let's open the
fridge again when will daddy lemon like
them alive
yeah same hostess
down in the food roomy this smells
really bad word is it dead animal that's
what it is
yaks forever yeah agreed yikes forever
[Music]
she's not having any of it I want to be
jealous like I just drink that no no no
no no no Gertie you want to be beards
then kit no I'm joking
yeah okay let's go outside
[Music]
let me I'm going outside
I'll be back in two please
[Music]
she doesn't care it's afternoon
misfortune remember Brenda meanest books
yes is where I first saw him he was
hiding in the trash and we made eye
contact he was rolling down Fox already
you shouldn't trust a fox they're all
criminals criminal that's stealing
losses were daddy else dumped it
what oh that I was like in the swimming
pool
wait I wanna have a look at the get in
that my mouth like our toilet pickles I
feel it a lot is disgusting not as
disgusting as when my body puke and that
was disgusting huh agreed that was
hey mr. midnight me when I try make
friends of animals so before we continue
you need to know the rules of the game
is fortunate Oh remember you will be
given choices on your journey
there is no right oh okay only
consequences when you beat the game the
prize of eternal happiness is your well
the robbers hands are right or wrong
choice then move the next mission gotta
beat it right cross this road or you can
do that look to the left look to that
way any course no
okay what monster I didn't see anything
it's probably just your imagination stop
standing there little girl have so much
fun oh the crew is dead haha
the crew is dead look a sleepy bird yes
come on you guys thought you let's go
now hey crow look after your friend
please
you're gonna go find Benjamin
Oh No koulikov the die
it's okay can we have glitter I should
have put a glitter on that burn
cool but I'm gonna copyright content
give that their copyright straight
there's
I love this what it's like so cute but
so dark and so when everything was so
hilarious
oh that was too sure man I wanted to
know what my what my choiceless did I
don't know why I am talking like that
I'm sorry Oh No
well that was a short and sweet video I
hope you enjoyed it
that was the little misfortune demo and
I have to say it was so damn good
police news please if you haven't seen
Fran bow I will leave a link to the
playlist in the description below Fran
bow was an amazing game the storyline
was great it's just so imaginative with
ideas that I have no idea where they
come from and I actually did interview
them as well I try and find that and see
if I can put that in the description but
yeah it's just extremely unique ideas
and it's simple but that's what I love
about it there's so many games now where
they just try to complicate things and
it's all about kind of being the best
and everything and now it's it kind of
takes a it takes a backseat through the
complex gameplays and stuff but this
it's just nice it's like reminds me of
just when I was a kid and I used to just
get absolutely lost in games
weeks at a time this is following two
stories like like my shin area and stuff
like that you know the art style has
definitely progressed and there are
elements of Fran bow that are still
prevalent which I really enjoy
the darkness the the surprising moments
but also the cute characters that you
can't help but really enjoy to like
listen to so I'm this shut up now cuz I
guess the point where I don't even know
what saying anymore but I'm excited for
this let me know if you liked the looks
of this demo and if you want to see more
when the game does eventually come out
anyway have a lovely day or evening I
will see you soon goodbye
[Music]
[Music]